hello Internet you're watching mostly
weekly and I'm intermittently andrew
heaton
interns the muse of Hollywood studios
who like to ask what if an intern was a
hilariously out-of-touch old dude
the answer is hijinks this summer
millions of students across our great
land are working in internships how do I
know because we asked our mostly weekly
Entering Clint to do some fact-checking
and some work around the set and
according to his research the US has
eight bajillion unpaid interns so why
the companies love unpaid interns
because the labor is cheap if not a bit
unreliable we were proud of you Clint
you're doing companies want cheap labor
and college students are willing to work
for the experience and job seekers who
are willing to work for free in order to
get a foot in the door of the company
they like with many companies are
eliminating their unpaid internship
programs altogether why because most
unpaid interns are illegal in fact the
exact wording says the employer that
provides training derives no immediate
advantage from the activities of the
intern and on occasion its operations
may actually be impeded so in other
words you can hire an unpaid intern you
just can't let them do anything help
Foot Clan I think maybe you misspelled
helpful in the teleprompter buddy just
know Clint don't be like that
why you got I'll let you come in at
10:00 here's the thing I think two
consenting adults should be able to do
whatever they want with or to each other
and that includes internships unpaid
interns meet a network of people you
could only meet through the wonderful
world of work and finally understand the
movie office make references references
are an incredibly valuable way to find
work you can only get by having work
experience in the first place
back in the days before unpaid
internships I used to give my own number
as a reference and pretended to be my
own former employer oh I hit ins a great
guy I for detail all that stuff knows
Microsoft sweet and
auguste all right it's the bagpipes
go-go Bev up to you my word auntie
weakens tall drink of water but never
had no drug charges another benefit is
worth lessons without an unpaid
internship we're a buddy you've got your
finger in the lens can you take can you
move your finger you just move your
fingers up that's not doing anything
okay I'm just gonna work around you I
work lessons they're important you can
get them from unpaid internships there's
also a suspicious number of congressmen
who have unpaid interns but also voted
to increase the minimum wage but also
use unpaid interns eggplant don't don't
walk in front of the green screen so for
them it's fine to work for $8 an hour or
zero dollars an hour but nothing in
between
hashtag Congress logic look unpaid
internships aren't ideal it's better to
get paid I know but it's also better
than not having any opportunities at all
wanting to ban unpaid internships is
like wanting to ban hot pockets because
we don't have both hot pockets and pizza
and let's at least consider things from
the perspective of the employer if the
government forces an employer to pay
their interns what possible incentive do
they have the higher with
twenty-something nobody for 80 something
days that's not even enough time to
figure out how to work the fax machine
or in Clint's case fax I love you buddy
weirdly working for free can be an
advantage for someone looking to get
experience but companies face increasing
legal scrutiny to hire them which is why
we should legalize unpaid
hello hey plant buddy
well how'd you get there I cut the blue
wire
[Music]